ladies and gentlemen we are now catching
up caught up with superman lois episode
three of season two hey thanks for being
patient with us and so yeah i think just
because of the way our shooting schedule
and editing schedule has been i think
for just safe measure i'm gonna say
superman and lois will consistently be
going up on thursday mornings that just
seems like the smartest bet on our end
at this current moment in time uh so
yeah that's uh that will be our upload
schedule for that we good all right hit
that like button that would mean a lot
subscribe click that notification bell
you'll notify when our reaction for that
is up of course and also full length
watch as long as we sing it with a time
code for snl or over at our patreon page
big thanks to all who become superjects
your support means more than you know
and also the boys at prepper you are the
uh
jordan and jonathan of our channel
you're both super though in nri you guys
are great
[Music]
i'll call my dad see if he can get us
credentials you don't think a surprise
visit from lois lane might raise a few
questions it would but not one from me
no helping us figure out what was
causing the earthquake i want from you
you promised now john
i know
but is there anyone else you can go
through right now
i love your wife clark i'll do anything
for lois you need to stop obsessing over
timmy it's not like healthy really
coming from the guy that
was up all night what looking at
pictures of his own girl again that's a
different story man
i want her to not have kissed someone
else
care for a girl's opinion
oh just that she hated keeping that
secret from you
which i mean maybe you can sympathize
with you know the whole half alien son
of superman thing i mean that's a
completely different kind of secret oh
yeah it's several magnitudes bigger
she's not wrong yeah dude
if you want to be honest with her about
your powers one day
would you want her to be cool about it
or would you want her to react how you
are right now
he didn't cheat on her
it's a personal line for everybody
they're extremely excited about the fact
that there is a woman running for mater
that's true what culture
who knows what it's like to feel unsure
of yourself
who knows what it's like to feel
incomplete she looks so familiar who is
this it's really bothering me come on
i i just think it's time to be honest
and tell her you know everything you
mean about having powers yeah like all
of it
no
do you realize if she told just one
person our entire family would be
compromised yeah but she wouldn't do
that or she could become the target of
someone in the future who wanted to know
my identity is that what you want oh
what if i want to marry sarah i'm 15
jordan so so get in the car i i want to
marry her dad you don't know that yes i
do no you don't
[Laughter]
he used the voice
that
kind of scared of the [ __ ] yeah
yeah i know it's like a possession movie
just that
of course john ryan they're like always
you this day would come yeah
no wait that's not living here
i stockpiled sam's old kryptonite
weapons just for this occasion
that kiss meant nothing i want to be
with you i i love you it's not about you
then what's it about no i don't know
where we go from here
it's not you it's me i have to decide if
i'm gonna marry you or not
only then can we date
he took some stuff at deuce or slavin's
lake house party a few weeks ago i
didn't think it was a big deal
what it made him
like stronger i guess so i don't know
but it's not even like a real drug it's
like some crystal crap that only grows
in small village
why didn't you tell me this earlier i
wish i didn't tell you now you're
already freaking out i'm not
oh
finally jonathan's powers arise this
blows candace's head off building a
sound economy based on regional industry
and agriculture and using this rare gift
we have
to reinvest in us and like kyle said i'm
a woman
[Laughter]
but weren't you the one recruiting
people for the man who almost destroyed
this town no one knew who morgan edge
really was chuck right another thing you
weren't aware of huh that gonna be your
answer when everything you're preaching
now doesn't come to pass
we're supposed to vote for her over
george dean when she can't even answer a
simple question
this podcast is having some mystery
guest on who's just gonna lie and say
whatever alston wants your sister know
about this she has to she probably knows
who the podcast is working with they
were all in that group at the same time
oh my god is her sister the guest her
sister it's got to be everything i
discovered ali and lucy were doing
everything i wrote in my piece and you
still can't pick a side
you didn't read it they do
don't bother talking to lucy for me
i will do this without your help
like always
[Music]
she's by far the best actor on this show
in every regard
she really is some of those skills might
rub off on you eventually
yeah so you can go for the
drugs you've been taking too
you're gonna go knock the gains on me
now
whatever man oh yeah of course
cause it's your girl who's the one who's
hooking me up what
bad idea
he's going to blast you
i thought clark was coaching today oh
jesus
oh god he got knocked down or is he
faking it i think he's just covering
really well
you don't just lash out at people like
that okay well i should have been the
one out there
jonathan get out of here yeah doubt
oh my god
this is so scary
dad
dad we need to go home now
dad we need an exorcism because like i
gotta let this out that's so scary
jesus christ what happened to your hands
that's my heat vision i i couldn't stop
it wow rage aholic strikes again this
was different
dude
this is a national security situation no
it is a family situation anything
kryptonian that can affect clark can
also affect the boys and besides until
we hear back from john henry we don't
even know if that's what it is wait why
do you need to hear back from my dad
forgot you were living here
you really gotta pay attention to who's
around
i don't know if my dad ever yelled at me
like that
this thing uh it feels like the end of
the world's coming up
not the time to go all doomsday on me
they keep saying
god this has to be a misleading
my bloody kryptonite oh god
i think you're right
taste it
son of a [ __ ]
it's that nationwide
does somebody set off explosives
yeah you knew that was coming
they did
so just women taking control
woke culture in my superman i don't know
dad i love her i don't think that's ever
gonna change if any year from now you
still feel the same way then maybe you
and i can have a different conversation
really
really in the meantime
i may have something to help show sarah
that she still care season three sarah
finds out
green is good on the superman world i
just wanted you to know i read your
article
a lot of grammatical errors
i have some revisions
ali alston
is a bad egg and your sister never
should have gotten involved with her
which is exactly what i told lucy when i
called her what'd you say most of it i'm
not gonna repeat
but she did agree to meet with you don't
uh
scare her away
lucy isn't strong like you
she needs a delicate touch
maybe she's stronger than you know xk
everyone's juicing
i'm trying to be this perfect person
that everyone wants and it
feels really fake
i have an idea oh
yeah come on
hurry up
oh i want to have kids
kids are pretty resilient
i mean my mom abandoned us and my dad
was never around and i turned out okay
okay might be tread carefully bit of an
understatement because you're perfect
okay there it is that's what i was going
to say the whole time yeah
[Laughter]
get back oh back
[Music]
it's freaking out
i'll call john henry
he won't be able to stop it
whoa
oh no
[Music]
michael chiklis
it's collaboration
irons do you copy irons i can't get him
to wake up
wake up fire rhythms indicate he's
unconscious
only now
wow holy [ __ ]
holy [ __ ]
damn
damn damn oh
crap
it's like watching the injustice game
that is awesome
damn got that hbo money
oh ain't doing [ __ ] come on man
he must just absorb all that power
that's not doomsday
[Applause]
that's him
[Music]
that's gotta be bizarro oh my nipple
just got so hard
yo they like straight up cloned him you
won't like this clark but i gotta call
anderson sam no there's a bizarre
version of superman on the
you're not superman your suit can break
you can get hurt i know why are you
doing this because they need my help
i don't want you out there again not
until we do something about this suit
[Laughter]
so you got to fix that thing up busters
are completely shot cpu needs spirit
that's awesome
this is going to be the best bonding
experience of your lives what am i even
going gonna say to her babe i haven't
seen her in years just be honest tell
her that you've missed her she's still
your sister lois no matter what luzaro
[Laughter]
so go ahead ask me anything ask me about
smallville
ask me about my aunt jenny's marinara
sauce that my daughter's obsessed with
hey
your dad said i could come in
yeah did you tell you not to run away
scared this time yeah he did um
oh it's kind of intense
i almost ran away so is this gonna be a
good talk
or a bad talk i think you should open
this first
will you marry me oh my god thank god
my grandfather gave to her back when
they were in high school when he knew we
wanted
and you're giving it to me
yes
because i love you sarah
you want to stay together
yes
for a really long time
does that mean jordan gets to kiss
someone
yeah you could go one hop last night
use it wisely jordan
john
so i had a little chat with timmy today
about where he gets his drugs from i
would like to buy some if you're here to
dump me just do it okay for the record
this that's why i didn't tell you in the
first place okay i knew you wouldn't
understand i think your joke is gonna
turn true
i've been worried about this whole time
and i'm not here to convince you to stop
selling
you're not
no i just
i need you to sell something to me
damn it man
not like this
crap hello lois
lucy isn't coming
yep lucy's been reeled back in she
thought it would be better if i came
instead
it's like a [ __ ] fincher movie
adventure movie
color palette the angles the lenses
[Music]
whoo
damn that's crazy
wow
oh damn oh yes your first bizarro title
oh nice
that's cool ah i'm glad the show's still
good yeah that was amazing
best episode yet that was that was uh
that was a really great stuff this is
actually genuinely
genuinely a really good like great
episode and it's really pulled in it was
like
nobody said something in
episode two
about just it not feeling like it was
like soaring and like yeah like locked
in great on its stride but you know
still really good yeah this was like
pretty much from beginning to end was
like oh no this is his life we're locked
in this was the show i missed it yeah
absolutely 100 all right cool let's chit
chat yeah my memory of bizarro's not
like the the the strong my my
introduction of bizarro must have been
the 90s superman i have a very specific
memory of like
clones of clark and then he sees like
uh dudes clark save their superman save
low saying he's like super bad save
loads or something
and and then uh there's like you know
bizarre has been i think he was actually
introduced in super boy if i'm not
mistaken okay yeah oh and there's been
talks about like maybe jordan becomes a
super boy
so it's just it in a way it's cool to
get that and and and there are
clues like it didn't make it wasn't
quite clicking with me of like why would
doomsday just sort of be down there i'm
not with no
prior fanfare or or yeah like personal
lead up to how he was formed yeah yeah
yeah so um it was like it seems like
they're doing doomsday and they keep
saying doomsday
and so they were obviously trying to
mislead and then
you know when thinking about the gloves
too at the time of filming i couldn't
find any photos that resembled it but
then eventually
yeah i think in like earlier renditions
sometimes he would have suits with the
gloves so i think like everything was
about misdirecting god
but then with the knowing what the dod
is doing and then you know uh like the
amount of duplication of powers and
stuff
yeah like there's a it's not far-fetched
they've got to a point where they could
finally clone superman but he's
basically like a
messed up clone version of calo yeah
i think i think his power set can be a
little bit
if i'm not mistaken i think it's a
little bit like opposite effect what it
can do i think instead of like heat ray
vision it's like freeze ray vision okay
or is it hot that's how i think it's hot
right yeah hot breath
and i think like you can only see
through lead but can't actually create
anything else oh yeah but there's like a
bunch of different versions of him like
sometimes he's just like like
unintelligible zombie version and then
there are versions of him that are
intelligible and it seems like you know
starting him off here that they're gonna
i imagine they would develop him to be a
character who was like i'm a little bit
more zombified yeah then eventually
grows into into a more uh fully formed
uh yeah
character motivation or at least some
kind of way we can dramatically connect
and have an actual internal conflict
between him and clark in some ways i
might be way off base here i've always
sort of viewed
bizarro as like
uh if solomon grundy was a clone of
this is this is getting us one step
closer to maybe having a solomon grudy
at some point true on this show but no
yeah i i wasn't he
didn't uh bizarro superman figure
heavily into the like apocalypse
animated uh
it was like a justice league uh that was
recent i
i got i get the mixed up uh on the names
but you know like he had taken over and
it was one of the more recent like
animated movies that had a horror tone
to it and uh and it was you know kind of
in in line with uh when the snyder cut
was like dropping or whatever but um i
don't know i appreciate that maybe i've
seen it so much i the topic it was kind
of a blur to me there's there's one in
which yeah like you know like dark side
wins or something like that and then
bizarro superman's in charge and uh
and yeah like yeah i've seen that i
don't really remember but maybe right
but yeah like i don't know that was
probably the last time i saw him in
animated form but uh it get it got me
really excited to hear
partly because of just all the like
horror move like they've put in these
really effective horror movie flourishes
both with like the crazy freakouts and
things but also just in the timing of
when they put in these attacks or
especially in this episode really kind
of making it feel sort of like a
alma like it it almost reminded me of
like a 70s possession movie but with
more of a crazy modern like james oneish
sensibility of like yeah when you
are like in james won movie a james bond
movie i could have got there much more
efficiently if i just said that
uh yeah but that like when he yeah has
that freak out and he has to like clear
the the you know pent up heat vision
into his hands like is really gripping
and jarring and unnerving and to have
that coming out of clark at the same
time as yeah this
sort of nightmare version of him is
emerging it feels like a really
significant character to kind of throw
in like right at season two but uh like
i love the way that they're making these
personal to superman without having it
feel too like silly or wrote or cliche
about it
yeah because i think the one thing with
superman is like there's
a lot of us to make superman interesting
it seems like something that other
people often default to is like dark
superman yeah
and and i think what they did clever
here was what happens when he can't
control his rage on his family yeah
which is like the scariest thought of
them all yeah like he can he he has the
capability of
just murdering his children and he
doesn't even he gets so blindsided by
his rage it's like sometimes a rage
could i like the metaphor of that
because sometimes rage you feel like a
blackout moment for people
and
like when he was talking with
lois about what happened with jordan you
know i'm sure there's like more sci-fi
[ __ ] going on in his head
but the correlation of
i don't even remember what the
conversation was really about i've heard
that happen with people like serious
rage issues is that
they just can't even recollect the
details of what happened in in the
blowout moment uh so yeah it was scary
and the way they built that were because
like you know with jordan at least it's
like well george probably took a hit
but
i want to be good
jonathan alone in the locker and then
like to me that was even scarier because
yeah like oh dude that guy has no powers
yeah yeah he can't withstand the laser
blast right now and uh yeah watching him
just be like a
father on the verge of committing just
domestic violence possibly immersion is
a scary concept and then
um
you know what that must be for the
children to have to be on the receiving
end of that
i think is a bold ass move yeah
absolutely and it's funny to like to
talk about sometimes i feel like people
like give up on on us when it comes to
criticizing something
because you know we had that or like
questioning something because we had
that thing about the whole plot with the
cult yeah and
and uh
you know like this kind of feels like it
came out of nowhere yeah and like all
right
but then it became like vastly more
interesting oh yeah and proportions are
way more on in this episode for that
story especially and now that it is
becoming so much more personal to lois
and it's really revealing and they
brought her dad back in
yeah and you're actually you know seeing
the presence
of this cult leader character whether
ali alliston uh like actually you know
stepping into first just on tv and then
into the actual narrative of the show
like you know yeah they made those
moments really hit and i think
it's funny like having it be about yeah
cult and true crime podcasts like i
liked that they then accented that with
some little finchery flourishes to
really pull you into the kind of
different sort of psychological
nightmare of that sure
yeah
yeah that's a good point
because there's a lot of nightmarishness
about this whole thing
everyone's like really anguished
and now jordan's gonna have a drug
jonathan's gonna have a drug problem
he wants to be like pop yeah
yeah it's it's about time jordan uh
jonathan did something yeah that was
really cool like
overly questionable about it
because it makes sense you know like
what the horse he did last season like
get a little drunk yeah and like get a
little mad
but but he's been the best boy the whole
oh yeah he's getting his mvp for the
heart of the show just like he's always
is so understanding the guys guys
pushing through a corner now man yeah
he's getting surrounded but he's in
enough at home he's his brother and his
dad have the greatest powers of all time
and
then at school his girlfriend is like
going behind his back and then he can't
play because the guys do interesting it
just makes sense that eventually he's
gonna do something else you know not he
can't be perfect so yeah i want to see
how that progresses of course um
but the
like who plays lois lane again why am i
busy
she is just so like she is she is
fantastic like tyler is
absolutely perfect in this role too i
just think that
her performance across the board
the
just due to the fact of how her
her portrayal lois lane has to carry so
much trauma
and doesn't like play it in a way that
is um
like
look at me traumatized you know yeah
yeah yeah it's not acting pills yeah
i think i think her performance is so
great yeah like constantly is is like
every
detail of her for portrayal is perfect
and it's it is cool to like get these
stories of like here's what clark is
dealing with here's what lois is dealing
with and then they have that moment on
the porch where they become like
lovey-dovey with each other
and dear you like oh yeah this is the
the partnership that's so good like this
this is just such a great like package
yeah of a series and then you have
um john and natalie
and the bar like i love the way that
scene was actually yeah because i was
like here we go yeah here we go
they seem to have a really sharp
awareness for those kinds of things
because they have really conscientiously
timed both those those plot lines that
could become very tedious like natalie
being upset at the circumstances
surrounding lois and john and and like
jordan and sarah like all that but
they've really conscientiously timed
those things out too then in moments
like this make you go oh god oh nice
yeah yeah like the way the flip of the
dialogue started happening like i don't
want you going out there again my mind
immediately went to ah how long's the
scene gonna go
like i can't do the scenes connect it's
necessary yeah but it's like in the mind
that the wheels just start turning of
like we know that eventually she's gonna
have to get on board with this stuff
let's like drag this out yeah
you're good at not spinning your wheels
don't start no we need to have this
conversation and then immediately to
just like a line or two later
to go like not until the suit is back
like oh [ __ ] that is so like great
because i think all of us were probably
in that boat they keep does they set you
up for her to just be like
yeah and she's always so uh you're like
why is my dad out there she watches the
suit fly off and this is worry concern
oh and the [ __ ] action was great too
yeah yeah like they really do get that
hp money on this show because yeah like
they make especially the the fight that
ensues between superman and bizarro like
and and the lead up to that with just
all the soldiers like they really made
that stuff scary and it hit hard like
all the hits felt harsh in a way where i
forgot that this was again i feel like
i feel like cw shows are cursed with the
compliment of when they're particularly
good you forget that they're seen
and that was absolutely something that
that happened here i had that one shot
in the air
yeah oh that is some of the best like
flying
characters in flight fighting each other
like in sky is can so often go hard to
do so terribly wrong like it you some
more often than not it just looks awful
it's like a terrible green screen which
way are we going and that looked great
and it's like broad daylight yeah and i
was so impressed with uh the way they i
was really really impressed with the way
they handled that uh just that one
little moment it was like watching like
the injustice game and the way that's
realized yeah um
so
yeah because there's not like masking it
with overshadowing it yeah it makes it
hard to see yeah it can feel more real
or just like let's have them just
crashing into buildings yeah look it
looked really really great you know
especially for a tv show
um
because that was movie quality you know
it's like i think i think zack snyder's
man of steel uh the the fight in
smallville is is like my favorite
superman fight ever
uh but
the that to see on a tv show and be like
damn that's like flight fighting yeah
like that because they don't do that
much in the in that in that fight scene
there that's pretty much on the ground
yeah they're like up in the sky you know
it's just
yeah i don't know how it was
i was so impressed with that moment it's
transportive and cinematic in a way that
you're not entirely yeah in a way that's
in some way almost unexpected but that i
think is a really thing it's something
that's really magical about this show is
that you have those elements they're
really plugged in there's not always
action but when there is it's really
kind of
accentuated to the 10th degree as much
as it can be and then you have great
character stories
and you know it's like this could all
feel kind of
like a soap opera and yet somehow it
doesn't really
no i was kind of getting soap opera
vibes in like the second episode yeah
yeah and i feel like they they've come
back up to like okay these are just you
know like these human struggles that
intervene while also crazy science
fiction and also cult crime stuff is
happening
uh and and we had a lana running for
mayor that's that's oh yeah yeah i'm
figuring that out oh yeah yeah there's
so many plot lines in here i know
it's so much fun and yeah it doesn't it
didn't feel overloaded and nothing felt
like it was too short except that we
didn't get to see them play madden
that's true that is true seeing them
play map
uh yeah i like the um
i just think the way to handle bizarro
is so good like it i it just seemed like
it must have been bizarro
with the
because they're obviously setting them
up for a big villain right yeah
and i was like it's visaro
and then he went away i'm like uh [ __ ]
do i have to cut that out of the video
because
it's actually blue superman it's just
a clone
but then to go to the fortress of
solitude yeah and then he's looking upon
it he's got the cape it's like
yeah you're like okay that's the that's
the confirmation yeah i think that's
correct 100
that's so cool well that's the thing is
like i i love that it's
like the first season you have yeah that
that pitch of you know you've got morgan
ed who's kind of uh taro who's kind of
like an inversion of superman in an
ideological sense for him to butt up
against with and now it's gonna be in
the most physical sense you know oh but
back to what you were bringing up with
um
her running for mayor and all that
i think she should have prepared for
that question
i think she should have prepared for
that question
well i think you have to do like what i
learned
it's classic debate if you're running
for politicians you know like i used to
go on like screen junkies movie fights
and the number one thing
i have to factor in when i'm playing
that game
is
what can they use against me and how can
i counter this or how can i defend
myself you know yeah like that's the
number one point of like i think
especially if you're running for
politics absolutely you gotta first
think people are gonna come at you of
what's everything people can attack me
on or question me on and you gotta have
that really thought out like you gotta
map that on like that question that was
brought up
like i don't really feel like you should
have thought of i have some
arena of this
yeah morgan edge wasn't that long ago
and that's something that at least like
for forget those mortgages yeah like you
know
absolutely and then also too then to
wrap it around at the end i i really
liked the moment between her and sarah
where they're figuring out a new way to
do the campaign
although
and i'm sure it'll evolve as the show
moves on but but in that moment i was
also thinking this doesn't exactly seem
like something that will immediately
counteract the events of earlier today
because like it's much more like
you know it's it's more personal and fun
than it is sort of like no
i'm back and i'm prepared
uh but that's just like a tiny little
i don't know
knit no i i got you like it was like a
cute moment but at the same time when i
was watching it i was like
but she's gonna she might get you're
being recorded now yeah so you might get
questions here that might stump you yeah
and you might get comments that are
pretty vile yeah like is that dude from
earlier gonna see this video and be like
oh no you're a person you're cool you
know i forget about my question and my
farm that i lost yeah yeah yeah yeah
um trust me there's people who've done
live streams yeah you really need to be
like oh [ __ ] people immediately
and and i don't know like especially
yeah it seems like people are apt to
jump in and really derail you if you're
in politics especially
um immediately especially if you're in
politics and then you have a past that
might that could be questioned
people will jump in and attack you yeah
and they like to do it in a live setting
yeah yeah oh yeah those uh god what are
those called uh conference
what kind of conference calls were those
called again town halls town hall yeah
yeah um yeah so that was kind of the
yeah i don't know
but the the moments with sarah were nice
there's i like the character i like that
they do the gray area with with that you
know yeah
like she
i don't talk at all about that
girl
all right
i do hey you know
i i like the way that they played that
because it was sort of like
i don't know if that's my thing maybe
but yeah it happened and uh i'm not
ashamed
i thought she was talking about cheating
then well i guess that's probably the
root of it but i feel like it's it's i
feel like the thing is it's harder for
me to look at that as just simply
cheating because it is sort of like a
discovery moment of another variety on
top of you kissed somebody
so in that sense i i
maybe that's just me kind of projecting
that on to it but i kind of took it in
both
because like the the cheating yeah i'm
like i feel like you
that i would be i would be ashamed of
that but it's good that you were honest
about it whereas like oh i kissed
somebody who i didn't think i would
normally kiss that i wouldn't feel the
need to be ashamed of it yeah oh yeah
of course not to be ashamed of that yeah
the um
but of cheating in general there's a
better argument to be made
for why you might feel a little bit
i don't know really don't feel better
and then to the person she gets like
well it didn't mean anything i mean
that's a bummer
meaningless kiss was the one
that caused all this promise i would
want it to be at least important which
which it does seem like in a human
context but yeah
um but i'm glad i i love the human part
of him being in love and what i'm
thinking because i know that's when
you're like a teenager in love and
you're like this is it
yeah because it's like it's so it's so
like uh
so grossing yeah it's like such a new
feeling you're consumed with this other
person yeah that first like heartbreak i
don't think you ever forget that first
like a real heartbreak that unique
feeling of having your soul ripped like
that but it feels like so literal when
you literally feel like you've been dr
strange punched out of your head yeah
yeah she's just floating in there
walking around with the heart that's
empty yeah yeah so um yeah i i i really
like that humanism like jordan your
wants are gonna change like i think that
was that was so real yeah it feels like
for all ages
it is because
yeah they didn't talk down to that
position that jordan's in which i feel
like you know for adult writers is
probably a pitfall that is harder to
avoid sometimes to really make that feel
natural and to
not make it feel like well obviously
dudes like you know he doesn't have the
perspective yet it gave it the credence
and and the sort of tenderness that yeah
just like every perspective is given
it's you know it's uh yeah it's credence
guys
cher knocked it out of the park
what can i say
perfect what more is that a saying it's
amazing guys leave your thoughts down
below
is everyone shout out um we got up some
more patrons to shout out if you want to
shout out some more patrons from our
from our special shout out here
yeah why not
kathleen maher
kiss me mr crispy
chris bostin
be thrust in clifford the big red dog
rodriguez sacks the crooked captain hook
jaren wanner bananer yale ferguson
person
[Music]
nick x-ray specs
rosalie taylor the valor
bear in the garage also a lodge
phil leiter
the weisser william bryant the fire
hydrant
kusi kusi
lucifushi
ericons 3969
matt i use some more audio than the
rodeos shaquita bonito washington
logan burton b flirtin
zack hershberger with extra onions
ricardo martinez
zombie shin on needles and pins
i think that's what your name is we
think we did google we did it we we did
our best dude yeah comment below and
tell us what your name is we went
through the the uh very we traveled on
horseback
riding library
cross-referencing ancient tomes
i think these two characters line
uh yeah all right guys americans thank
you so much for um being here yes
support means a lot catching
[Music]